all right we are now live for another
reading from my book a reason fulfilled
by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in
france we have done four live readings
so far and so this will be number five
and we're getting into a new section of
the
introduction at this point so this will
be a little bit longer than
last reading but about the same as the
others so far um before i get started
let me um say that the reason i'm doing
this
is this is the 10-year anniversary
of publishing this book that took me
roughly about what about uh
six years of research and then a couple
years of
writing and editing and things like that
going on
and so people you know were asking me
about it i realized
10-year anniversaries are probably a
good time to start doing
this this kind of thing and i'll
probably once i finish all of these
readings be doing some some videos
specifically
about some of the key ideas in the text
so this is from the introduction
starting on page um
there we go a little picking the wrong
thing page 46 thematic introduction
outline of positions articulated during
the debates
having sketched the historical context
and unfolding of the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in the previous
section
in this section i intend to provide
fuller more systematic
exposition of some of the interlocutors
positions
developed in the course of the debates
to specify precisely the purposes and
limits of this section
five connected points need to be made so
first
i caution that the studies presented in
this section are in fact
bare outlines aiming at providing main
theses
judgments and distinctions of the
various interlocutors contributions to
the debates
i attempt not simply to summarize but
also to allow these authors to express
themselves in their own words providing
translations of terms and short passages
but a considerable amount of what is to
be found in their writings
has necessarily been passed over to some
degree simplified here
this raises the second point which is
that these outlines are
not designed to entirely substitute for
let alone replace
in-depth examination of the documents
cited
the goal is instead to facilitate and to
provoke
further study of the debates the
philosophical and theological
interlocutors
their positions and their texts
third the outlines are designedly not
comprehensive in another way in that
summaries are not provided for a number
of the documents and authors taking part
in the debates
some of the interventions are of clearly
lesser though
not entirely trivial importance than
those selected for inclusion here
providing assessments of them remains a
task for a longer and more detailed
study than is possible here
fourth the amount of space devoted to
the authors and texts corresponds to a
deliberate
choice to balance attention to works
that either still remain untranslated or
cannot be translated for example the
lengthy and important discussions after
jolson's
society frances de philosophy
presentation
with attention to overviews aiding study
of text translated here
also more attention is given to the more
manageable
body of text from earlier on in the
debate a basic motive again being
encouraging further anglophone
scholarship on the debates by providing
a few clear inroads in the previously
unknown or at least unexplored terrain
accompanying this is the motive to
demonstrate
where that early on the debates offer
much wider scope greater complexity and
depth of insights than is typically
believed or taught
precisely by rendering a portion of its
literature more
accessible to anglophone readers the
fifth point
is one particularly necessary to make
namely that these outlines are validly
the products of my own scholarly work on
the debates and their documents as such
though i have attempted to represent
them as fairly and as accurately as
possible
these studies remain flawed partial
perhaps even on some points in error or
misleading
the only possible remedy for this of
course
is emendation by my peers engaged in
further
critical and informed scholarship on the
debates the figures the texts and the
very notion
of christian philosophy so that's the
the introduction to this section
here's the next sub-section the
rationalists
emil brejier and leon brunchfig
the positions staked out by brahir and
brunchfig early
in the debates incarnate two different
attitudes
of the french rationalist mentality
and establishment towards christian
philosophy as blondel would point out on
certain points they were actually
incompatible still their two positions
are broadly representative and both set
out clear
and well-structured sets of challenges
to which any position
arguing in favor of christian philosophy
would have to respond
since brayer's position arguably sparked
the debates and is in certain respects
both bolder
and cruder than brunchfigs his provides
the natural starting point
is there a christian philosophy from the
start brehier correctly pointed out that
the key issue was not
a purely factual one resolvable simply
by noting the historical existence of
philosophers
who were christian and philosophies
developed in christendom
instead there was a question that had to
be resolved
normatively and brahir envisions only
two types of resolutions
each providing a possible concept of
christian philosophy
either it is a philosophy deemed
acceptable by religious authority
as in accordance with dogma or
alternately
it is a philosophy developing in some
positive manner
from starting points or an inspiration
provided by
christianity while granting the
historical instantiation of christian
philosophy's first sense he maintains
that this cannot be genuine philosophy
since reason
uh here we go yeah since uh
since reason and whose free and
self-critical exercise philosophy
consists
is subjected to an authority outside
itself
the second sentence must be evaluated by
turning to history
considering significant possible
contenders for the title of christian
philosophy
in each case breger argues no christian
philosophy faithful to both terms is
generated and thus
there is no christian philosophy he
begins with the church fathers and saint
augustine
and judges them to merely adapt greek
philosophy to christian uses he reads
into augustine
an unbridgeable gulf between logos as
the fixed immutable world order
sought by greek philosophy and logos as
the incarnate word of christianity
as well as a definitive choice for the
latter rendering his thought
non-philosophical turning to saint
thomas aquinas and conceding that he
distinguishes philosophy as an
autonomous science from religion
and theology he argues that since thomas
makes christian faith the measure of
truth thus an index for the adequacy of
a philosophy
he withholds from reason and philosophy
their own initiative
autonomy and criteria of certainty
a condition that he holds they cannot
legitimately
accept an unduly weakened reason
is thus subordinated to faith brahir's
interpretation of 17th century
philosophers stresses the opposite
dynamic for their projects
of employing unharnessed reason to
demonstrate truths of christian faith
generate genuinely autonomous
philosophies with no intrinsic
connection or
need to culminate in christianity
interestingly he invokes pascal's
criticisms of cartesianism but does not
consider
his thought as a possible christian
philosophy
19th century philosophy offers two
different candidates both
using christianity to order and organize
their philosophical systems
traditionalism distrusting the
individualistic abstract emancipated
reason of the revolution
makes religion specifically christianity
and language into the necessary
requirements for the proper
exercise of reason in the process
turning christianity into a mere
means for an organic social sphere
brehere points out that the endpoint of
this is comps positivism and religion of
humanity
he designates a similar endpoint for the
hegelian experiment in christian
philosophy which rationalizes
christianity
on a yet higher level in foyer box
atheistic
humanism the last philosophy he
considers is
blondels which he dismisses with a
dilemma
either it is christian apologetics from
the start therefore not philosophy
or the problem of action it focuses on
gives it an ethical direction with no
intrinsic connection to christianity
brahe and the associated front says the
philosophy
session after jill stone's presentation
brahia responds first by reiterating
and fleshing out his earlier distinction
ascribing christian philosophy
to extremely distinct senses he says in
a first sense it exists
but it is of no interest to philosophers
in a second sense it would have
interest for philosophers if it did
exist
but it does not exist in his view
determining what christian means
requires recourse to the views
and judgments of some designated group
which adopt in catholic parlance he
terms a
magisterium although this criterion then
permits some philosophy to be
denominated christian by the religious
authority
this is something extra philosophical
taking the catholic magisterium as an
example
he points out that the scope of its
purview seems to vary
considerably in different eras the
result is quote an absence of precise
limit
in the philosophical domain this
magisterium overseas and a lack of
consistency in its censure
these make christian philosophy in the
first sense to be something completely
arbitrary he then supplies a formulation
for tackling the second sense
the question is knowing whether
christianity as such insofar as revealed
dogma
has ever been the starting point of any
positive philosophical inspiration
he bases his own response on his
historical research from which he calls
two main interrelations
between hellenistic philosophy and
christianity for one they share the same
basic
subject he says the essential dogma
characterizing ancient philosophy is the
dogma of a word
a dogma of a logos a dogma of reason and
thus its fundamental concern is
this universal notion of what is
rational in things and in human thought
of that through which the divine or the
reasonable can penetrate into things
christianity is also concerned with the
logos christ
and thus similarly with knowing what the
intermediary between god and men
god in the world is he goes so far as to
maintain that christianity and
philosophy
raised exactly the same problems
and to affirm that what continues to be
essential
in philosophy is always under one form
or another the existence
in reality and in the mind of some
element that is connected to the
divine yet while asking the same
question they differ in the method by
which they ask it and breher identifies
this difference precisely
as between an eternal notion of the word
which invites us to a rational
explanation of the universe
and a history a mysterious history which
cannot be known
only by revelation and which thus adds
itself from the outside to the
the eternal notion but which does not
add anything
to it right here concludes with another
lapidary
and indicative formulation he says
christianity is essentially the
mysterious history of the relations
between god and man a mysterious history
which can only be revealed
and that the substance of philosophy is
rationalism that is the clear and
distinct consciousness of reason
that is in things and in the universe
brunchfake in the society frances de
philosophy session
while braggiere sets out a position
marked by clear commitments bold
formulations and rigid dichotomies
joson's former professor proposes a
considerably more
nuanced position requiring considerably
more
work to pin down exactly he begins by
admitting i would not
recognize myself in what i think and
what i feel
if the entire movement of christianity
had not existed and ends by according
maul brush
the privilege and the honor of being the
representative naturally not the sole
representative but the typical and
essential representative
of a christian philosophy but along the
way
he introduces a further refinement into
the problem and argues that most
contenders to the title
feel either as christian or as
philosophy
he suggests that an adverb be appended
to the term
so that the issue becomes one of
specifically christian philosophy this
is in turn he argue
this in turn he argues introduces a
dilemma if one is a philosopher
the substantive remains in some way
immovable after the adjective in return
if one is a christian
before being a philosopher and rather
than being a philosopher the situation
is reversed
in the first horn of the dilemma there
is nothing specifically
christian about the person's philosophy
his use of reason his procedures his
assumptions
remain the same as those of
non-christians he says the author of
a system of philosophy can assuredly be
christian but this is only an
accident without any relation with that
philosophy
as we would say for the author of a
treatise of mathematics or
medicine brunchfig devotes more
discussion
to the second horn christianity's basis
is in christ the incarnation of the
messiah
something exceeding reason and therefore
providing no foundation for
philosophical reason to build on
the philosophy and christian philosophy
will then as he says designate a process
of thinking
a movement to progress of the entire man
but one that
directly overturns reasons regular
procedures
pascal provides an exemplar for this and
brunswick grants that
it is legitimate to consider pascal as a
philosopher but this comes with the cost
of considering him a philosopher in some
way beyond
pardes in french philosophy
on the horn of this dilemma we grasp he
says the deep meaning of christian
philosophy where the adjective
radically denies the noun an admittedly
pirate victory
if his christianity has taken possession
of the entire man he writes
it is by uncovering for him a way of
philosophizing
that is not that of philosophers the
implication
being that such a way of philosophizing
cannot rightly be called philosophy
brunswick is also willing to place saint
thomas aquinas thought in this category
but adds that it also lacks the properly
rational meaning of philosophy because
that re the reason that precedes the
17th century had not yet arrived at
maturity
he does however grant the possibility of
something it would be appropriate to
call without equivocation and without
compromise a christian philosophy in
fact he identifies maul brash as an
example of this
he writes this is the case where a
metaphysician reflecting in a manner
deep and naive
at the same time would arrive at the
conviction that philosophy ends up only
raising problems and tangling itself in
difficulties
the clearer a consciousness it will have
of these problems the deeper
it will sound the abyss to which these
difficulties throw philosophy
the more it will be persuaded that only
christianity's own solutions will
satisfy the philosophical
problems he could perhaps have singled
out blondel
on whose dissertation committee he'd
been a member for this third possibility
brunchfig's rationalist idealism also
introduces a new wrinkle to the problem
challenging the very distinction of
divine revelation
and its contributions from the products
of human reasons such as philosophy
similar to hegel
braunschweig holds that quote faith
insofar as faith is only the
prefiguration the sensible symbol the
approximation of what properly human
effort
will be able to set in full light
considered in this light the thomistic
baptism of aristotle completion of
philosophy the aristotelian type
by a theology through imagination of a
supernatural
and transcendent order would involve
conflicts of two modes of what is at
bottom
properly human thought though
brunchfig's rationalist interpretation
of
revelation in his larger works seems
weakly supported
by invoking the problem of pre-judaic
babylonian egyptian etc
origins with conscience of so-called
revealed dogmas restricted to the
faithful of a particular cult
during the debate he raised an important
issue not addressed by many of the
interlocutors
the significant of involvements of human
beings faculties and even culturally
conditioned and mediated disciplines
in divine revelations provision and
transmission
all right next portion revelation
generative of reason etienne joseon
buttressing his position by interpretive
exegesis of key figures from medieval
philosophy
jill so argued for the demonstrative
historical existence of examples of
christian philosophy
he also probed into the bases of various
groups rejecting its possibility
criticized what he took wrongly to be
the blundellian position
argued for the legitimacy of the notion
of christian philosophy and provided
it a number of characterizations and
definitions all told jillson produced a
coherent robustly developed position
still regarded
as the definitive one by many
contemporary proponents of christian
philosophy
the notion of christian philosophy
in his society frances de philosophy
presentation the form
joseon's approach takes to the entwined
questions of christian philosophy's
possibility
and correct notion is reminiscent of
thomas aquinas favored framework for
addressing issues
he begins by reviewing three positions
opposed to christian philosophy's
possibility
then brings up augustinian positions for
it while recognizing and appropriating
valuable elements and insights from
augustinian positions he criticizes them
as insufficiently philosophical then
after having thus cleared the ground
articulates his own position
two of the positions opposed to
christian philosophy rationalism and
what he calls theologism
offer similar resistance because they
share a number of assumptions in common
but argue towards the same conclusion
from opposite ends deriving from
radically different valuations of
christianity
and philosophy from the theologist
perspective
quote where christianity is it is
useless or dangerous that philosophy be
likewise from the rationalist one quote
where philosophy is it is dangerous that
christianity should be
where the rationalist sees in religious
faith dogma or authority
forces inevitably restrictive and
corrosive of the reason that provides
philosophy's principles essence and ends
the theologist or fetist sees in
philosophy and unsupported
human reason a temptation to prideful
knowledge
incompatible with christian faith and
salvation
for rationalists by its being christian
christian philosophy degenerates into
mere apologetics
and thus deviates from the search for
truth wow for fetus
by its being philosophical and idiolates
christian revelation and life
the third the neo-scholastic position
holds that since both are grounded in
truth faith and reason are ultimately in
agreement
but that a christian dogma in revelation
can at most supply philosophy with a
negative criterion
of its adequacy and full use of reason
it cannot provide any distinctive
starting points prince
principles of inference proofs methods
or conclusions to philosophy
which would then be transferred to
theology
philosophy is and must be an enterprise
carried out by employment of a human
reason
that remains the same whether in a
christian or non-christian
joseon discusses three main augustinian
positions for christian philosophy
the first being augustine's own project
involving philosophical assimilation
and unfolding of truths believed by
faith in which
in the conditions of its exercise reason
enters into intimate relation with faith
the second position takes the form of
medieval and modern interpretations of
augustine
construed as christian philosophy
against peripatetic and thomas
philosophy
holming in on the third which consists
in contemporary analogs to the second
position he differentiates quote the
thomistic attitude
towards the concrete from the
augustinian saying augustine always
seeks notions comprehensive enough to
embrace the concrete in its complexity
st thomas always seeks notions precise
enough to define the elements that
constitute the
concrete in a word the former expresses
the concrete
the latter analyzes it for
the augustinian in a christian
philosophy christian persons philosophy
authentically grasping and grappling
with the concrete
faith and reason become fused into unity
resulting in a christian philosophy
but while producing as he says a correct
description of the reality to be
explained
augustinians refuse to provide its
explanation by carrying out philosophy's
task of analyzing it into concepts
joseon sets both bergson and blondel
into this category
and while conceding the the validity of
their critiques of raiification of
abstractions
argues that their rejection of concepts
and the philosophy of the concept
renders their work something lesser than
philosophy
with the implication that neither could
therefore supply a christian philosophy
there is however a vital insight to the
augustinian position
which becomes a keystone in the edifice
of jill sohn's position
namely the real unity of philosophy and
christianity
in the philosophizing subject human
subject
likewise faith and reason are rooted in
the human subjects in which they exist
and come into fruitful contact we do
possess
concepts of the christian religion and
philosophy corresponding to their
essences
but they do not possess existences
independent of their subjects in which
they are united
and integrated and so a christian
philosopher's reason
is not something different from the
reason of a non-christian philosopher
but it is conditioned by the coexistence
of non-rational christian faith
in the philosopher against those who
would cease on this to claim that
christian
the christian's reason is thereby
beneficiated zhilson points out that
every philosopher's reason coexists with
something non-rational
he follows that up by noting that the
christian philosopher is quote
convinced of the rational fertility of
his faith and sure that this fertility
is inexhaustible christian philosophy's
rational legitimacy
having thus been established historical
research
can be carried out to discern whether
there can be found quote philosophies
that is systems of rational truths
whose existence cannot be explained
historically without taking account
of christianity's existence since in
them
christianity played a significant role
in the constitution of them
within such philosophies christianity
would have opened possibilities for
further determinate development
of rationality by philosophy
so that in the concrete human subjects
engaged in philosophy christianity
proved to be a
revelation generative of reason right
that's where i got my title from
while rhetorically leaving the
historical existence of christian
philosophy is an open question to be
decided by research and the question
whether such philosophies possess
genuine value to be one for rational
critique
in the context of his body of previous
work and commitments she also leaves no
doubt
that he considers these questions
definitively answered in the positive
all right
society frances de philosophy
discussions with breger and brunchfig
as the main presenter jilson engages the
two rationalists in debate
immediately after their presentations
the first quickly devolves into a near
complete route
for breyer while the second is far more
evenly matched and inconclusive
joson leads off by grasping brayer's
dilemma by both horns while granting
that the christian magisterium
acceptance of philosophy is an important
element of assessment in order to
determine a philosophy's christian
character
joseph stresses two points first the
actual historical workings of the
magisterium are more complex than
brahir's oversimplified picture grants
more importantly quote the totality of
ecclesiastical
decisions whether positive or negative
would not in any manner establish a
system of philosophy
since magisterial declarations bear on
the compatibility of philosophical
doctrines or
systems with christianity not on their
value or status as
philosophy so even though no such list
has ever been produced if the
magisterium promulgated
an ideal catalog of philosophical truths
this would generate a theological
not a philosophical document thus
christian philosophy in the first sense
brayer grants it
does not exist in its second sense
he argues that it does exist joseon
candidly admits
i follow a different historical method
than brahir and he goes to suggest
that his opponent's interpretations go
beyond the support
of textual evidence by paving over open
questions with unargued for assumptions
joseon writes
i agree entirely about the primordial
importance of the doctrine of the logos
but i do not recognize for myself the
right to say
that it is the philosophical question or
even the
christian question my personal studies
and as far as i know those of
others are not advanced enough so that i
could dare to make such an affirmation
he points out another problem there are
non-christian
notions of the logos does this prove
that there does not exist a specifically
christian notion of it
for if there is one we find the
existence of christian philosophy
proved on the very ground where one
wants to deny it he further
problematizes two assumptions underlying
brayer's interpretations of augustine
quote are the philosophical truths saint
augustine says he found in platinus's
work independent of all christian
influence
was what he says he did not find there
indifferent to the philosophical order
both of these would have to be true
for mr breyer's thesis to be proved but
both of them seem
doubtful to me jill soon then cites his
interlocutors own
texts in which he maintained a
difference between
the jewish philos logos and christian
logos and downplayed augustine's
dependence
on greek philosophy in this way after
having said that there is no christian
philosophy you add that
it is only with many precautions and
reservations we may speak of the
platonism of saint augustine that
self-knowledge
has a different meaning in augustine
augustine's and platinus's works that
as in the case of self-knowledge
augustine's interpretation of
intellectual knowledge sets them apart
from platinus how do you make these two
theses agree
brahe's response to joseon's criticism
character
characteristically shifts the ground of
his argument
he says doctrinal continuity is
something of very little importance in
philosophy
everything is the method the way that
one sees things the rest of their
conversation
consists in joel saul methodically
pressing point
after point and right here backpedaling
from his position
into assertions either progressively
more vacuous or dubious
again citing his opponent's own history
of philosophy jill saul says
you show us for example that in saint
paul's works there are stoic elements
but you add that properly understood
christianity's fundamental trait
is absent in epictetus's work whose
pascal said did not know
man's misery and who makes man his own
savior
there is that in saint paul a
fundamentally different attitude from
that of a stoic philosopher
this case exemplifies the jolsonian
understanding of christian philosophy's
development
and is set out in a concise argument st
paul was introduced to a point of
philosophical anthropology man's misery
but in a non-philosophical way since
according to you
these speculations must end up later in
pascal's passage
there is despite everything philosophy
at the end of this perspective
it was therefore implied in the starting
point and though there's actually no
philosophy in saint paul's text it was
able to be
generative of philosophy
this leads jill son to ask a general
question formulated two ways
of the christian influence and
philosophy has it not produced
specifically doctrinal rational and
speculative differences
and does it not seem to you that there
are ideas basic and extremely
extremely elementary ones about which we
would have to have a discussion
the effect of judaism and christianity's
monotheistic conception of god furnishes
a specific example
and provides occasion for the spectacle
of brahir
first expressing doubts whether
monotheism entered into philosophy from
christianity then from judaism then
whether it's moral influence and
philosophy derived from these religions
then when jill stone pins the issue down
to the way in which it had an influence
on metaphysics whatever it may be is its
origin philosophical
purely and exclusively rational right
here suggests this remains a problem for
further study
joseon retorts actually christian
philosophers have interpreted these
words from exodus ego
as signifying god as being no longer
simply the good as in plato
or pure thought as in aristotle where
does this come from
he sweeps aside the suggestion that it
does come from aristotle
and when then when brejier brings in the
question whether exodus his formula
would have been treated philosophically
if aristotle's theology had not existed
he rightly points out the rationalist
confusion
of two different issues i do not know at
all whether there would have been a
christian philosophy without a greek
philosophy
but that doesn't prove that there has
not been a christian philosophy
they continue the dispute moving to the
conception of creation
which introduced the idea of beings of
existence's radical contingency
no longer that of intelligibility or of
order as in greek philosophy
brahir first tries to claim that
creation is found in plato's emmaus
only to have pointed out that the
demiurge is a rather different
and lesser notion not involving
generation of being itself which enters
philosophy through the biblical creation
account
he then brings up the fact that all
philosophers make recourse to the idea
of creation a point whose irrelevance
jill observes saying my thesis is not at
all that the christian revelation
introduced philosophical ideas that are
valuable in every time
and which would be universally valuable
at all times the question that i
ask is that of knowing whether it did
not introduce ideas
that became philosophical and valid for
authentic philosophers
the discussion between brunchfig and
joseon immediately centered on the issue
of rationality
and contestation of the former's
dismissal of pre-seventeenth-century
reason
as underdeveloped again joseon uses his
opponent's
own text he writes the fact that for you
as you explained long ago in the
anterior anterior direction
of esprit that there is no true
rationalism except in nominalism's
lineage does not prevent there being
another meaning
just as or even more legitimate of the
word reason
the two philosophers circle each other
sparring first over the philosophical
legitimacy of the aristotelian exercise
of reason
a conceptual and not nominalist exercise
and by extension philosophies
for which there are concepts and admit
the reality of the concept
then the judgment of predication
developed and relied upon by the
peripatetic tradition
comes in for comparison with the 17th
century rationalist judgment of relation
the interlocutors do not really come to
grips
until jose argues at length that quote
for saint thomas aquinas philosophy was
perhaps aristotle in a certain sense
but that what was original in the
philosophy of saint thomas aquinas flows
much more directly and more deeply from
christianity
than from aristotle himself joseon
sidesteps brunchfig's earlier raised
problematic about revelation
and the supernatural order by clarifying
the commitments of his position
it suffices for my thesis's requirements
that what of philosophical sources can
be found in the bible are not
encountered there in a philosophical
state whether the bible derives from
god's supernatural revelation or from an
imminent religious human intuition quote
the result would be the same
for the origin of philosophical
speculation is not itself
philosophical the question is knowing
whether there exists philosophy
that has come from something that is not
philosophy
according to joe song thomas aquinas
philosophy
not only furnishes an example of this
process even the concepts and
terminology
it borrows from aristotle are
transformed in the light of the
christian revelation's contribution
he then turns explicitly to the
rationalist interpretation
of 17th century philosophy
arguing that even in pascal's case there
is a generation of philosophical ideas
in contact with his faith and his
religious life
his choice of poscalion discussions of
the two infinities as an illustration
of christianity contributing notions of
the divine that go beyond
greek conceptions thereby enriching the
historical development of philosophy
elicits a double response from brunchfig
on the one hand pascal would not have
gotten his conception of the infinite
from thomas who as an aristotelian
conceives the totality of being as being
finite
on the other not only was his conception
of the quote infinitely large and
infinitely small
derived from modern science and instead
of recognizing
there what you seem to see a sign of
god's infinity pascal felt it as a cause
of man being crushed
precisely by reason of the impossibility
of the physical universe leading us to
god
brunshfig concludes the infinite for
saint thomas before copernicus
as for pascal after galileo is inhumane
inhuman it is not divine this would be
rather a surprise to thomas and as
you'll see points out while the notion
of the infinite plays a different role
in saint thomas's
natural theology than in that of pascal
the notion of an infinite god
is common to both and it's closely tied
to pascal's metaphysical speculations
their portion of the debate closes with
some degree of agreement about pascal
and mel brush
the real difference lying in what their
basic assumptions about philosophy
entail for their interpretations of the
two
for braunschweig in pascal there is no
philosophical thought properly speaking
that is not impregnated by christianity
in each of its movements
and this disqualifies his work as
philosophy
joseon does not regard this as a problem
he says i do not see why
even for a man like pascal one would
have to say that christianity absorbs
philosophy to the point of suppressing
its existence
to the contrary i would see quite well
pascal's acceptance of the supernatural
order engendering in his work a
philosophical plan
for he distinguished the order of
thought from the order of charity
the latter infinitely superior to the
former
he ends on the only note of complete
agreement with brunswick possible the
assessment that
maulbrosh is a christian philosopher and
a link
in the chain of the history of christian
philosophy
two other important engagements 1932
1933.
in his gifford lectures the spirit of
medieval philosophy joseon provides the
sorts of detailed and systematic studies
he had deferred in the society francis
de philosophy session
and referred to as necessary to truly
decide the issue in favor of the
historical actuality of christian
philosophies
since that work was long ago translated
into english and a sizable body of
scholarly commentary and criticism it
already
exists i will simply indicate five of
its features particularly relevant
to the context of the debates the first
is that the bulk of the work
is devoted to detailed exposition of
numerous classical examples of the same
basic dynamic
of christian revelation providing
occasion for novel
philosophical development the second is
that his
approach in his approach to each of
these notions issues or experiences
contributed to philosophy by
christianity jose also sketches short
histories of their appropriation
transmission amplification and
reinterpretation within
traditions of christian thought
presenting a picture
rather more complicated than
christianity once and for all
seeding contributions that then
philosophy labors on incomplete
independence
this leads to the third feature a new
definition
of christian philosophy he says i call
christian
every philosophy which though although
keeping the two orders
formally distinct nevertheless considers
the christian revelation
as an indispensable auxiliary to reason
it includes in its extension all those
philosophical systems which were in fact
what they were because
a christian religion exists and because
they were ready to submit to its
influence he again stresses
that the concept does not correspond to
any simple essence
susceptible of abstract definition but
corresponds
much more to a concrete historical
reality
as something calling for description
implying that the definitions he himself
supply require as support the sorts of
descriptions provided through his
interpretive exegesis a fourth feature
of interest is
his expanded critiques of three
positions construed as his main rivals
rationalism neoscholasticism opposed to
christian philosophy and blondel's
philosophy
the latter targeted not by name but
under the aspects of a philosophy open
to the supernatural
and of those who without denying
legitimacy of philosophy would
incorporate christianity whole and
entire within
a fifth particularly interesting feature
is that christian philosophy is framed
not as an entirely past actuality
but as a present and perennial
possibility medieval christian
philosophy exerted
he says its influence beyond the limits
of the middle ages and will continue to
exert its influence
as long as there are men to believe in
the possibility of metaphysics
even more generally the formation of a
christian philosophy was inevitable it
is still so today
and will so remain as long as there are
christians and
christians who think just
also became directly involved in the
conversations after both sessions at the
society
thomas second day of studies provoked by
the intransigence of pure mondonet's
remarks
he begins by saying i had made a promise
to myself not to speak that makes a
number of illuminating remarks and
answers first he points
out an inconsistency in the purely
personal or extrinsic relation between
philosophy and christianity
held by the neo-scholastics
the if he says if there are factual
relations between
faith and reason between revelation and
philosophy in a concrete subject it is
impossible
that there is no normative relation
although the formula is classical and
entirely satisfies them joseon concedes
himself willing to give up the term
christian philosophy and notes that it
better needs to be provided
because the expression designates a
reality namely the enrichment of greek
philosophical thought by the
by the christian contribution bruno de
salaage
asks of jill so whether christianity's
new contribution is similar to the
influence of another great philosopher
or of a philosophical school introducing
new ideas
or does this influence possess something
particular to it something that doesn't
resemble
any other influence just so answers i
have the impression that no the
influence is not of the same order when
our philosophers
received the notion of god as being or
that of creation
they were especially struck by two
things their perfect rationality and
that nevertheless
reason alone had never been able to
discover them
what a philosopher gives over to another
philosopher is something rationally
inferred and demonstrated what saint
justin saint
augustine and saint hillary found was
something rational that came from an
extra rational
source responding then to mondonet's
repeated insistence that what
he and by extension mar 10 means by
christian philosophy is simply theology
joseon articulates the distinction
between philosophy and theology from a
different set of angles than usual
there is an essential difference between
the attitude of the theologian who sets
himself up in the revealed data and asks
reason what the revelation is and the
attitude
of the philosopher who sets himself up
in the rational order and asks what
faith in what matters it may enrich
reasons knowledge
the fact that reason and faith play a
role in theology as they do in
philosophy
does not at all imply that they play the
same
role there the theologian's conclusion
is always something
revealed whatever appeal he may make to
reason that of the philosopher is always
something
rationally demonstrated whatever appeal
he may make to faith
another interlocutor moss novo argued
that christianity's relations with
philosophy were for the most part
extrinsic
it could have an intrinsic relation only
that philosophy graphs
quote its powerlessness to completely
resolve the problem of life that itself
raises
and in which it essentially consists and
the consciousness derived from this of
being pushed to seek out
by another path the full solution a
seeking that
ends up factually in christianity mos
novo's formulation contains echoes of
blondel
and jill saul makes several points in
response
he contests the unduly restrictive
interpretation of relations between
christianity and philosophy
he writes for a christian even the
fetase ex
audi tu when it is received as such does
not seem to me
to constitute an extrinsic relation he
suggests that such interpretations do
stem from quote the necessary correction
of an imminentism
quicker to attack others than to define
itself
clearly having in mind blown down
against whom he makes the vital point he
could only have conceived that system
because he possessed the christian
revelation
even the determinate shape scope and
contours of a philosophy open to the
supernatural
cognizant by pure reason of the
insufficiencies of nature and its lacks
or the insufficiencies of reason and its
lacks
become undeniably different when seen
through the eyes of christian
philosophers and after centuries of
christian
influence all right so we we close off
there
the next section is philosophy in a
christian state jacques moratan
and then catholic philosophy maurice
blondel which we will
read next time um that's that's actually
a good chunk there and then we
we have after them neo-scholastic
thomas opponents of christian philosophy
thomas proponents and then finally
non-thomistic proponents and that will
take us through the entire
uh introduction so
um a lot of reading there hopefully you
found that interesting and useful
um corey says this is a great listen
after playing worship music at church
today as
is sort of like an intellectual feast
uh you could say i um
you know when i come back to this stuff
i'm struck by
how interesting and
brilliant and stylistically astute
most of these interlocutors these french
speaking philosophers were even though
the ones who are against christian
philosophy are making
eloquent cases against and you know this
is a really
um interesting set of debates i make the
case
in this this book early on and really
throughout it that
the issue of christian philosophy has
never had so many
top-notch minds working on it as
during this debate so that doesn't mean
that everything is encompassed within
these debates
but if you want to think out the issue
of christian philosophy
you really probably shouldn't try to do
it
without you know some
some engagement with the the debates and
fortunately
um you know we have some of them some of
the documents
translated here there's also joseon's um
spirit of medieval philosophy there's
there's other works as well there's
probably a lot more translation work
that could be done and maybe i'll do
some of that
down in the future
silent hunter says amor fatim doesn't
really have anything to do with this
uh it's a stoic thing or a nietzschean
thing
uh ricky says i find this very
interesting and that's that's good
uh the silent hunter is basically just
showing off his latin here i'm not sure
why he's looking for
that sort of thing anybody got any any
questions comments specifically about
the topics the
thinkers the debates the questions
raised within them because that's that's
mostly what i'm i'm
you know going to focus on here
um if nobody has anything then we can
always just cut this short
but if there are any questions about the
book the
topic the background those sorts of
things i'm happy to
answer them um
[Music]
i will point out that most of
joseon stuff maybe actually all of it
has been translated in one form or
another so it's quite easy to get your
hands on
um the other people who we mentioned
particularly
in this meal break year has a history of
philosophy that's in a number of volumes
that you do you will see in older
libraries right
um and then
brunchfig you know some of his stuff is
translated a good bit of it is not
all right david crosby how deep do you
feel the no the roots of world view
are nourished by the context of the book
i don't really quite understand what
you're asking so maybe you could
clarify that a bit world view can mean a
lot of different things
and the context of the book you're
talking about like
the debates themselves or are you
talking about the french context
so maybe you can maybe you can write a
little bit more about that silent hunter
says i like
like your videos just hopped on didn't
know you do
live chats i do a number of kind of live
chats i do amas which are general i do
these live readings you know says
exactly what we're covering here the
book
um i do uh political theory
and practice discussions every once in a
while i'll do a philosophy pop-up
so i do yeah we do a lot of live stuff
and you can actually find them on the
reason i owe calendar
on my facebook calendar uh and they're
also
generally once they've been scheduled
they're there on the
youtube channel where it says
live live chats right so all right any
other
questions comments um
cosmogenics has an irrelevant question
about getting married
um that's that's not
has nothing to do with the christian
philosophy debate so i'm going to pass
on that
that would be an ama question um so you
might want to ask that the next time
that we
come along with that uh any other
questions comments
things that you want me to engage
about the christian philosophy debates
about the thinkers
topics uh
ricky was mondel you mean blondel
making a case for christian philosophy
indeed he was
so jill song was
one of the main people making a case for
christian philosophy
jacques mara tanwas maurice blondel
maurice blondel those are the top three
guys
and then antanon certian thomas
very underrated thinker by the way
gabrielle marcel 18 born a lot of the
people that are being
discussed here are making a case for a
view of christian philosophy one of the
issues that arises is because
within the christian thinkers some of
them
are in some part wrongly criticizing
their contemporaries
as not having the right kind of
christian philosophy
all right so david says the influence of
present worldview so
how deep do you feel the roots of
present worldviews are
nourished by the context of the book
um
yeah i don't i mean there's a there's a
myriad of present world views so some of
them
obviously you know people who you know
follow it
also there he has followers today would
be
influenced by by him you know there are
some blundellians out there
um a lot of what's what's going on
like what we what they're calling
rationalism there we would call
secularism now
so um that can have some things b
does the does the debate have parallels
in other philosophical communities at
the same time
uh yes and no this debate is the
epicenter
and they have tiny little parallels
and we talked about this last time
actually in the so you might want to go
back to that video
uh reading number four um there were
some like spin-offs you know the
american
philosoph american catholic
philosophical associated by 1980
1936 was doing a session on it
the um uh you know uh
thomas society of ottawa did one but for
the most part it's it's happening in
france
or in in french-speaking circles um
and there were there was as i i also
brought up in the last talk
a reform protestant spin-off debate
that happened among francophone reformed
uh
thinkers in the 1940s
going on into the 1950s which is
independent of the dutch
debate that really doesn't reference the
french thought at all
um that people like alvin plantinga who
have read the dutch stuff but not read
the french stuff
uh were were revealed or were influenced
by
uh tony is there a connection between
the 1930s christian philosophy debates
and the modern apologetic of
presuppositionalism i don't see any
real connection between them um
silent hunter what the thinker thinks
the approver proves
i don't even know what that that means
so um
any other questions about the uh the
debates
the book the context
b what are the key weaknesses in
blondel's reading of his opponents
there's only one key weakness a lack of
a lack of charity and thinking that and
it's the same
weakness in jill saul and mauritan's
position
as so many other of the thinkers pointed
out
they each think that their position
joseon maraten on one side and blondel
on the other is incompatible with the
other person's position
when really they're complementary that's
that's the only real weakness
that that's there
and it's really weird and unfortunate
and it has much more to do with like
personality conflicts
and old beefs that those two
sets couldn't like come to productive
terms
um and it's interesting because because
blondel was not translated over here
um except for you know like accion and
stuff like that
and because jill so and mara 10 their
stuff was translated over here and they
did teach over here and they influenced
a whole you know like set of generations
of people
the jail marathon take became like the
standard take
even though it was on that point wrong
cosmogenics augustine of hippo why in
the east his teachings are more disputed
and were notably attacked by joan
ramedes
you pick any theologian and you can find
somebody attacking their stuff so that's
not
an index of anything augustine is
essentially a latin doctor he writes in
in latin they don't read much latin over
you know
past a certain point and they had their
own
other doctors that they were into you
know that's about it
damn it what would you say is the most
difficult aspect of translating
philosophical works
well other than like knowing the
language you need to actually know know
the language that you're translating
from
for me one of the toughest things
is being willing to say
okay this is probably as good as it's
going to get i'm not going to
tinker with this anymore or do
additional
research or writing because you
there is no perfect translation right
and
sometimes um you might think of a better
way of expressing something later on
but um you know
you can only get so far with it right i
i will say this i've been translating
works
i first my first translations were
actually from latin as part of the
aquinas translation project
way back in the 1990s as a
graduate student and then i
translated works from german
and french i provide my own translations
when i'm working from greek text
as well you know like uh epitidis or
marcus aurelius or i mean i'll consult
other people's translations
i have through the work of translating
become
much more forgiving of other people's
translations
you know than i was before
because i realize how how messy a
process it is
b has blondel had more influence on
later christian thinkers influenced by
post-structuralism than his
contemporaries
um no i wouldn't say so um
blondel's influence has largely been
within catholic circles
um and he had immediate massive
influence from the beginning
uh well actually before the 20th century
began
many thomas have been influenced by
blondel you know including
some of the ones that you know are
should be considered very very reliable
norris clark is a great example right um
and certian should have mentioned bruno
de salaj those are not
post-structuralist thinkers
post-structuralists tend to be um with
you know
it depends on what you mean by
post-structuralist too is is jean-luc
mario a post-structuralist
probably not because he doesn't engage
structuralism at all you know he engages
derrida
but is darida even post-structuralist or
is he deconstructionist
deconstructionist you know it's kind of
debatable
i would say that most of the thinkers
who would classify themselves as
post-structuralists
are really not interested in
christianity much at all
so um david would you
use scripturalism as a determining issue
at the time i have no idea what's meant
by scripturalism
that's that's not a term that generally
gets used and this sort of thing and it
could mean a million different things
we have to be very very careful in
throwing out terms
that may be taken from this tiny little
christian context here
with this you know you know community
and blowing them up to mean
you know uh like general terms that
everybody else would know
you always got to explain where the
terms coming from and
and what it means all right well we're
pretty much
at the end of the hour uh any other
quick
questions or comments or stuff like that
um if not i'm gonna get back on with
other work that i got to get done today
for my
my classes and we'll do more of these uh
in the month
um hopefully we can get through
maybe we can get through the rest of the
introduction this month
and then start getting into the actual
translations themselves
which are you know pretty sizable we
might have to break some of them into
chunks we'll see what happens but
all right um let me say
have a great whatever you've got left of
your day
and weekend um some of you if you're
far enough are already in the next day
um
most of you are you know either in your
afternoon
or evening time um so i'll
wish all of you a good little bit left
of the weekend
and i'll see you next time